his was the shrug that was seen around
the world last night
and gave voice to a lot of people who
just suffered a bad beat
you could say the cleveland browns
suffered one as well
he is none other than espn sports center
scott van pelt midnight eastern host and
so much more
back here on the rich island show how
are you scott
i'm better than the the browns plus
three
you know i i got to be honest with you
scott um and and i i
you know me being an nfl employee i
don't really
and this is true this is true i really
don't pay attention to that sort of
stuff
i don't i might have been one of the few
americans watching that
final dipsy do or whatever you called it
in your
highlight uh reportage afterwards what
did you call that play
again when you were doing the highlights
after rich that play is called pitchy
pitchy woo-woo
and it's the term the woo-woo
my friends and i for re reasons i
honestly don't know is the gambling term
we invented
decades ago to describe the play where
like something horrible happens at the
very
end of a game where you get crushed
some horrible bad beat and then the
pitchy pitchy thing is this new horrible
trend
where teams and northwestern really i
think gave birth to it
against ohio state years ago where brent
musberger famously said some people are
saying you've got to be kidding me
because they started pitching the ball
around
which by the way it makes sense it's the
only thing you can do to have
any hope but inevitably what happens is
in pitchy pitchy woo-woo is people start
chucking the ball all over the place and
they go 40 yards backwards and then the
other the defense just falls on it for a
touchdown
and then and last night the pitchy
picture resulted in a safety
which uh again unbeknownst to me because
i
i i just decided many many moons ago
not to even pay attention to it to even
be attracted by any shiny object that
friends tell me should be
uh a shiny object worthy of my attention
uh financially i just don't pay
attention that sort of stuff
and then game over then you show up
and you just shrug just like
you give a shrug and i realized on the
spot
oh god that's when i texted you brockman
right oh yeah
i said to you like that did that mean
something sure did
[Laughter]
scott that was amazing let me let's
let's just be like i understand it's i i
i
i don't i i appreciate the fact that you
don't pay attention
and i also know that that not everybody
is is
enamored with the topic but many moons
ago i
decided to deal with the elephant in the
room because many many people do
a lot of people bet on sports and as we
have seen
particularly over the last 12 months 24
months for sure
the pendulum is swung in the direction
of it being legalized more places
and the nfl has softened its stance to a
degree but they still haven't come all
the way full circle
and so as a result out of sort of
respect for the fact that the league
doesn't
fully embrace even though they have a
team in vegas and teams have official
gambling spark up
gambling uh partners and sponsors which
is a fun trick
i i at least am a little bit more
tongue-in-cheek about how i refer to it
hence
a shrug which you say nothing but you
say everything in that moment right
you sure did scott you sure did so walk
me through how you're watching the end
of that game
uh on your set
because i'm looking at the clock and see
this is terrible okay
anybody that we always call ourselves
degenerate gamblers like let's let's
just call it
we're just gamblers right any gambler
looks at the clock when tucker comes out
and you think
how long does it take to kick from 50
from 55 seven seconds
no it's gonna he there's going to be
time left on the clock
when he makes this thick answer you're
thinking when tucker's coming out
that's what you're thinking when justin
tucker's that's what you think when
justin tucker's coming out
that's what you're thinking well i think
that says well because i know justin
tucker is making the kick because he's
the best kicker in football sure so i'm
already working off the presumption he's
making this and there's going to be time
on the clock and just just so we're
clear
i have no action on this game it doesn't
impact my life at all
i'm just thinking content wise we could
be looking at
at a a horrendous ending here and so the
minute he makes it
there's two seconds left and you go well
here we go because cleveland's not going
to return it
and then there's going to be two seconds
left and what are they going to do
well they're going to start pitchy [ __ ]
before you know it like the thing about
that play rich
is that inevitably in five to ten
seconds
you're 20 yards backwards like it never
advances it it is it is incumbent upon a
thousand things going wrong for the
other team
but they never do and so you just end up
losing you've got 25 yards to work with
so very quickly you're on your five
and linemen are involved and you're
hoping somebody wearing a number that
starts with a seven doesn't have his
hands on the football
um and that never happened last night
but you could see it coming a mile away
and you know when they when landry ends
up with it in the end zone i'm just like
oh
heavens to betsy's poor people who have
who
and by the way it was going to be a push
right so like after all that game
which best game of the year spectacular
riveting action and and that's the main
topic of conversation for our show is
what a phenomenal game we got and lamar
coming out on fourth and five impossibly
and all of that but then the fact that
that incredible game
division rivals in cleveland all of it
ends like that is just this this perfect
little cherry on top of the sundae scott
van pelt here
on the rich eisen show and you are
spot-on i mean
what a game it was in a yes it ended
with a
uh gambling anomaly with uh
with the safety that meant absolutely
nothing because of the aforementioned as
you said pitchy pitchy woo-woo
that type of play that goes down and
then we saw all those rushing touchdowns
nine of them that were that uh tied some
record that happened you know
uh after arnold rothstein had eight men
out and all that sort of stuff and
you know um and and and
lamar taking the lead and then baker
taking it back
and then lamar disappearing so i ask you
sir
uh in the middle of all this uh what do
you think was in fact the
if you will pitchy pitchy woo-woo that
was happening with lamar
in the locker room and in the fourth
quarter saw your tweet about something
about
something about maybe the second time
they'd gone for two successfully
had successfully went for two because
that is what happened
again after he emerged he he himself
he himself said i didn't have a paul
pierce moment god bless paul praise you
guys
he's got a hall of fame career and
what's the reigning mvp references him
as the guy who pooped his pants
i mean this is a uh this is this is not
the best thing to be known for
and yet that was how he was uh yes he
was referred to
uh in that moment um i would say
yes i let's just say this and we're
being children right now
that's why that's why we're doing this
i'm more than willing to come along for
the ride on and be a child
um that that that sideways strut
towards the towards the locker room was
not the strut of a man it was cramping
um it was the shot of a man that had
what we call the green apple quick step
okay
that's the green apple quick stuff you
know what the the one thing
the one moment that sealed it for me was
when
somebody was standing in the doorway of
the locker room
and and lamar basically gave the guy the
arm movement of
get the hell out of the way i got to get
in there you know yes
yes very quickly very quickly sir you
need to move because i have things to
tend to
but all right all right i'll continue to
indulge this conversation
please scott that was i mean i think
listen
let's be honest we've all been there
we've all been there
i mean i'm letting you into the the
dwarfed mind of van pelt here with the
the terms that i use describe things
it's a poop panic attack we've all been
there you've got to it's like you're
seized with
terror you've got to find the toilet
yeah it's okay
it happens to everybody but if that
happens rich
you're that's that's a quick moment and
it's over like
it passes he was gone for quite a while
so
um i don't know that's that's why that's
why the cramping actually
it holds water for me well in terms of
the couldn't hold his well because the
cramping that part of it that does hold
water is okay
two things one is that if it was such an
urgent moment
he should have been back well before the
uh
you know the the second to last
possession of the game for him
and then uh also you know
this this this is a guy uh lamar jackson
who on this very show scott
showed that he cannot shade the truth
when i asked him how things were
appeared more difficult offensively for
him this season he's like yes
the defenders are calling out our plays
sometimes and and i
you know followed up after that to make
sure that you know
my simple question did not burn a bridge
torch it over the river kwai
with the ravens that this is this is who
he is he's just
a guy who just speaks the truth just go
and floats through life
you know as a heisman trophy winner mvp
winner
and i maybe he was basically telling the
truth but
but paul poor poor paul pierce just
sitting around saying
i'm watching a football game what's
happening right now
imagine that imagine that you're just
you're paul pierce your hall of famer
you're sitting around you're watching
the game like everybody in america
probably is just fortunate and then you
got to hear that
yes like that's how i got to get
referenced tonight i mean
you know okay i guess i'll have to i'll
have to deal with it but my god what a
game
and rich i mean and this is kind of
inside the beltway from a tv perspective
but you like the
you have the the the the teas
the two-minute teas there's a two-minute
warning yes they come to me
just to say here's here's what we got
coming up when when you know when this
game ends yep and sometimes
too many times sadly you know the game's
out of reach and it really you're just
sort of saying hey yeah
you're begging people not to turn the
television off but in this moment
everything's still on the line it's
about to be a fourth down and my
producers in my ear saying
holy bleep like jackson's back on the
field and i'm and i'm saying and they're
like all right 30.
so there's this countdown and i'm saying
is he in the huddle or is he on the
field he's like i'm not sure
like ten nines like jackson's in the
huddle i'm like holy so
we're coming for this suddenly there's
an urgency to this which is all right
after this incredible game yada yada and
lamar jackson is
back on the field handed to levy and
he's like it's fourth and five and he's
in the huddle
it was this impossibly um dramatic
moment and then of course he throws the
touchdown and then you know
and we weren't done from there so all of
this
absent what happened in that last play
of the game last night was as
captivating an nfl game as we've had all
year which you know is
is the treat we all are hoping for i
gotta admit to you scott van pelt i'm
sitting there i'm watching your
you know the post game show and um
in which by the way lisa salters
asked lamar if he had anything left in
the tank
was that was it was that was that on
purpose we
i gotta find that out and what a way to
post that question
you know the legendary john szawaski
interviewing technique i mean
i missed no yes or no there was
anecdotes for anecdotes for having had a
bathroom accident i don't know i know i
didn't i didn't get that in the
interview
no but i i got to spend you know i'm
sitting there watching your post-game
show
and you know not many times
in my current you know state of what i'm
doing these days do i sit there
and miss doing a highlight you know what
i mean like i i i
i don't sit around and sit there and say
you know
man that what a great game i wish i was
doing the highlight
watching you do the highlight last night
made me feel
that way and how to me scott the way you
do it
and your show in our world
i'm gonna get serious with the tv talk
here in our world
where everybody assumes that you've seen
all
executives assume you've seen everything
already in the palm of your hand because
of what's going on on twitter and
everything that there's no use
to stroll us down the way something that
we just watched
happened i i think that's a bunch of
crap
i i that and that's why your show is
crucial
in my mind in many different ways and
the way you do it i was sitting there
going man i wish i was doing this
highlight right now
watching you do it last week well thank
you you're welcome thank you for that
and yeah i i appreciate it
but you know having done it as well
and as long as you have that that that
the
nobody that loves sports is bummed out
to revisit
that highlight nobody like no one's
sitting there at
12 o'clock thinking well i just watched
this incredible game you know what i
don't want to do i don't want to hear
any more about that
i'm i'm right yeah you
you're sitting there going holy crap did
that just happen let's re
i want to watch it again and some
highlights are just highlights
but as you know games like that that
move you the way sports can move you
when they're at their best you you don't
have to fake the
enthusiasm you can channel your inner
stuart scott and
just be you know moved by the content
and and that's what last night's game
really was so i i and it means a lot to
hear you say that because
you've done this you know for many years
as have i
and so when you're sitting there
thinking this would be a fun highlight
to do i'll tell you
you're right that was that was a fun
highlight to do i mean so
much going on in that game with just the
way
it was started the way it went back and
forth the way
it ended so before i let you go into the
day
i mean it sure looks like lamar's back
like the lamar that can go
vertical the lamar that's he's he
slinged it around when he got it back
after baker mayfield took the lead you
know again
and and and or to tie the game again
and and he was running he got 100 yards
rushing i mean the
mvp of 2019 i think for the first time
all year showed up
last night and the browns are now
officially you could say
not the browns of old so uh you know
what to make of i agree with the
aftermath i agree with both those things
i agree with both those things for
i that that the ravens and and i asked
louis rudik and brian griese about it i
mean and
there's a bit of cliche in the idea of
competitive spirit and
and the idea of what being
uh a pro looks like but i think the
ravens demonstrated
both those things right you you've got
to have this game
and they figured out a way to win that
game and you look at their schedule and
it feels
it feels favorable the problem for the
ravens in my opinion is just that the
afc is so crowded
that it's they're just there's more
there are more good teams than there are
spots available for those good teams
so that becomes the challenge for the
ravens most notably
um but for cleveland and louis riddick
who
played for them and has a connection to
the city said and i agree
that what happened last night like this
isn't about years ago
and ernest beiner fumbling and
years of quarterbacks that weren't good
or whatever
but none of that has anything to do with
last night they played a hell of a
football game and they lost
but they played the kind of a game and
baker mayfield played the kind of a game
where if you were going to face them in
the playoffs you would think this is not
going to be a whole lot of fun
because they're they were capable of
answering every
time they had to answer so i think what
you saw were two excellent football
teams
that played the game of the year and it
felt every bit like a playoff game
animated with people pitching it all
over the field and um and then a bonus
two points
gave us a fun little segue to our goofy
little show scott
wins all around man it was great last
night uh watching the game and then
seeing you do your thing and that's why
i wanted to have you on uh to to
chitchat
about it get your perspective uh day
after thanks for the call i know you got
your podcast to do and um
and all being all sorts of van peltier
so thank you for the call appreciate you
my friend happy holidays to you and
yours and as always i appreciate you
being out there watching as as you
always know we're
uh doing the same with you guys so it's
just a big giant love and i'm hugging
you from afar attaboy
thank you scott that's scott van pelt
not the fakes
svp right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here